bonjour marcellin nadeau
bonjour morisod l'temps bonjour aux
auditrices et auditeurs de radio
martinique martin première et je salue
aussi l'équipe de la matinale chef de
file de l'opep la merci d'être avec nous
dans son crédit marcellin nadeau
comprenne qui pourra il a fait comme
monde qui prend plomb c'est presque ce
qu on a envie de dire ce matin lorsqu'on
regarde cette salve de soutien pour le
deuxième tour concernant l'initiative
comment les lectures martiniquais qui
s'abstient comment peut-il comprendre il
voir quelque chose tant il ya des
contradictions dans tous ses
positionnements des uns et des autres ah
ouais ça s'est fait comme 17 chansons du
goût cas là c'est chatte catete date et
la plainte était chez moi je crois que
c'est vrai ya de quoi perdre un petit
peu ses repères et c'est pour cette
raison que à nos peuples à nous voulons
essayer de redonner un petit peu
d'européens ça que nous avons eu cette
position très claire nous lissons que
gauche et droite ni l'ange y va ça ne
paraît pas être une bonne chose pour la
démocratie il faut que chacun tout en se
respectant
affirme ses convictions et nous disons
très clairement que dans le sud
lorsqu'il ya une opposition gauche
droite c'est la gauche en l'occurrence
jaffe des pony run dès lors il partout
ailleurs lui à ne pas l'avoir écrit
devrait officiellement dans votre
commune et non nous l'avons dit nous
avons dit le candidat de gauche mais
bien sûr que barney son nom ou et bats
la limite voilà bon c'est un oubli
peut-être ces nobles et c'est
certainement le mal qui ronge les élus
de martinique chaque fois de façon
récurrente systématiquement les élus
nous font le coup de soi disant avoir
une longueur d'avancé pour l'élection
d'après fabrice du nom chantal maignan
vaugirard et d'autre on a quand même
l'impression que c'est 2020 qui anime
déjà leurs prises de position non c'est
ça faisait le paysage politique
martiniquais marqué pendant cette guerre
des places un haut lieu de en lieu et
place du le des classes et je crois
qu'il faut absolument revenir aux
fondamentaux c'est à dire aux visions au
zoo aux idéaux valeur à une vision et le
politique doit proposer une vision à
l'opinion de se répéter pas si la vision
c'est quand la volonté majoritaire très
bien mais on a l'impression que les gens
sont plus dans des stratégies de
conquête de pouvoir
et depuis c'est ce qui alimente
l'expression d'une opinion tout ces
signalements d abstention selon vos
absolument les gens voient bien que au
fond ils se disent mais qu'est ce qui
porte si j'en ai est-ce que c'est
l'intérêt général est ce que c'est la
volonté de porter une vision politique
ou est-ce que c'est simplement le fait
d'occuper et même certains se disent si
on peut sous préfet bourguiba - oui donc
du coup et sur 2,2 d'exploser
effectivement des positionnements et
c'est très bien pour la démocratie mais
en même temps il est dommage que ces
positionnements se fasse en son substrat
sans substance politique et idéologique
est-ce qu'il ne vaut pas mieux se taire
après le premier tour ne pas donner de
consigne de vote tout simplement laissé
des lecteurs faire mieux en jeu qui loba
notre arrêt ce travail pédagogique
sommes des pédagogues ce que nous
faisons train notre position si redonner
des repères aux citoyens dit au fond
contrairement à ce que certains disent
il ya bien une droite une gauche qui a
des valeurs
même si on peut avancer balayé d'un
revers de main et celui qui arrive à
l'elysée celui qui aura une hyper
majorité à l'assemblée nationale
justement n'en veut pas tout le monde y
adhère
mais justement je sais pas si tout le
monde y as des as à dire que il sur ce
une sorte de roger effectivement de ce
qu'on pourrait appeler entre guillemets
elle beaucoup de guillemets une classe
politique mais je crois que très vite on
se rendra compte qu'un macron n'est pas
la boîte mélange à la gauche mais c'est
surtout quelqu'un qui porte un projet
néolibéral qui sera préjudiciable à la
grande majorité à la majorité sociale
notament à travers le détricotage du
code du travail aux sont les idéologies
les philosophies de vie les visions
d'une certaine société des discussions
autour de la conception de cette société
mais nou sé sa nou peuple 1 et 2 voulons
redonner du bal à l'idéal je crois qu'il
doit il faudrait un championnat dans sa
démarche mais non mais pourquoi vous
dites que ça marche pas parce que les
scores de vos candidats
lorsqu'on veut dire parler d'aujourd'hui
manifestement les gens n'ont plus
tellement envie d'entendre son nom mais
pas à cordes et il faut analyser y
finaliser très clairement déjà notre
score dans le nord qui un score plus
qu'honorable qu'est-ce qu'on promettait
amie lori bâtiment même anonymat qui mac
imac une implantation réel à la fois
dans le paysage politiquement ticket
dans le nord quand on voit le score beau
jimmy ferdinand qui était jusque là
inconnu
c'est quand même encourageant girard
allemand si commun l'animé rizon marqué
le débat beaucoup de gens nous disent en
fait
c'est vrai que nous peuple à a marqué le
débat pour ces élections il faut ajoute
encore que sur l'offre politique en
termes de citoyenneté
nous sommes trop nombreux il faut penser
justement que chacun sorte de ces et de
son ego la zone est bouclée le pourquoi
pas moi puisque personne arriver mais
nous on ne dit pas ça on est toujours
ouvert la discussion on est prêt à
attendre est outrée à débattre échanger
pour trouver les synergies nécessaires
de manière à présenter neuf politique
cohérente mais qui peut créer une
dynamique majoritaire c'est ça notre
ambition est le plus malade dans tout ça
marcellin nadeau celle homopoliticus et
les lecteurs c'est la société c'est la
démocratie
mais ce problème comme qu'ils iraient
sofer systémique on va dire dans le
système il est effectivement l'homo
politicus et puis y'a les lectures des
forêts qui comme le client et je crois
que nous sommes encore dans des logiques
clientèle et un clientélisme et c'est ça
il faut casser cette dynamique là pour
faire de la politique lui redonner ses
lettres de noblesse
parce que la politique est utile elle
est utile surtout lorsque les gens
souffrent des difficultés
elle peut permettre aux gens de porter
un projet de transformation sociale un
vrai projet alternatif loin de la
logique d'alternance qui veut dire petit
ghetto la madame météo - on verra
facilement l'expression on va revenir
nous fait la main dernières questions
concernant ses prises de position
concernant le deuxième tour des
législatives pour samedi prochain dans
le sud vous atteler très clairement à
voter pour jean philippe miller
heureusement qu'il est face à sylvain
ses soutes l'enseignement pourrais vous
dire que pourrait se dire que vous avez
soutenu quelqu'un qui était dans ce
fameux g20 qui était tellement décriée
oui bon ça va revenir ça va remonter à
leur nation monsieur sur la terminologie
que c'est vraiment pour dire que c'est
la guerre s'est passé pas très poli
alors sur la question il ignore quel
réminiscence du g20 mois le g20 j'en ai
pris mes distances très clairement génie
pourquoi parce que c'était une manière
pour certains d'amener dans un camp et
pour d'autres d'années dans l'autre camp
ça ne m'intéressait pas ce que je veux
douce reach on s'est créé une dynamique
la dynamique nous avons créé nos peuples
à travers le soutien à jean philippe
nylon en quelques pas c'est réaffirmer
la nécessité qu'il y ait des repères
qu'il y est vous savez j'ai bien aimé
dans l'édito de hyères de jabot reparti
et issoire d'arc en ciel à la fin le
mois quand c'était trop jolie je dis que
c'est on dirait en d'autres termes on
vous passez l'expression kréyol aussi
mais mais mais les gens n'y comprennent
rien
soyons sérieux il y à une question de
valeurs on nous a dit un premier temps
oui on va faire un contrat de gestion et
puis après on seulement semblent pour
l'heure mais ils vont faire quoi
savais tu que tous les candidats du soi
disant grands semblez vous avez 1 chance
ils ont la même vision politique parce
que hormis le fait d'aller je sais pas
demandez pourquoi pas des finances
supplémentaires pour la ctm
mais ils ont à se prononcer sur les
orientations libérales ils ont eu à se
prononcer sur celui d'hier ça veut dire
que yan monplaisir francis cabrel jean
philippe ni la cei sous tendent ces
mêmes buts mm balaye mais soyons sérieux
moi je crois qu'il faut revenir et nous
disons et c'est votre sur les dirigeants
de la coalition des coalitions nous dit
nous on n'y croyait pas vous savez bien
on disait déjà bon on nous parle de
contrats de gestion ont fait en juin
drapeau pour m'étonne drapeau pour
réaffirmer le drapeau c'était pas pour
nous de 2,2 de la gestion mais ton froid
bien que loin de la gestion eh bien on
me prenez pas franchement des stratégies
idéologique mais on est dans des
conquêtes de place et on salit pour
conquérir est classé secret et c'est ça
qui fait la file associant coalition de
mon cabinet sous de côté
non pas du tout nous peuple à 100
coalition mais cohérente autour d'une
charte de valeurs et qui porte un projet
alternatif
là aussi je me s'il ne revient cette
fameuse formule de ses erreurs le plus
large contre le plus étroit mais c'est
pas le plus large dans n'importe quelles
conditions
si le plus large la base de valeurs et
c'est ça nous peuple à ça dit qu'on
construit un rassemblement citoyen mais
sur la base de valeurs et c'est ça qui
nous manque c'est ça qui fait défaut est
ce qu'ils vont retrouver pour rien
chanter le paysage politique
martiniquais plat deviendra quoi ce que
on se rappelle décembre 2015 pour
l'aspect martinique score flatteur
législatif pas franchement succès succès
il s'agira de faire croire sachant qu'en
en 2020 il y aura des municipal bonds
c'est à dire qu'il faut aussi se dire
que il y a aussi toutes les questions de
notoriété qui peuvent entrer en ligne de
compte mais je crois que franchement on
n'a pas démérité
on a un bon positionnement et que
effectivement on sera encore dans le
combat demain dans les combats soit que
qu'ils s'agissent des municipales ou de
la ctm demain mais cette fois je crois
qu'il faut aussi essayer de rencontrer
les uns les autres tous ceux qui se
réclament de la diva serait un mot
vous allez devenir partie mais ses
proches vous savez un mouvement un parti
la sociologie politique ne fait pas la
différence maintenant on est sur la
conception la vision nous sommes plus
dans l'idée d'une coopérative politique
et c'est une idée qui a utilisé rama
yade et et qui a été défini très bien
dorée par cohn bendit je crois que cette
idée de coopérative politique un homme
une fois avec des principes
démocratiques
l'assemblée générale qui décide
l'émergence d'une délibération
collective c'est ça au fond nous peuple
a et c'est ce qu'on veut reconduire sauf
que ça peut prendre du recul sauf que
dans martin l'absolu sapera il ya une
demande d'expression citoyenne
ce qu'il faut aujourd'hui c'est que les
uns et les autres sortent de leur
nombrilisme sortent de leur égoïsme
sorte de deux de leurs deux dotés du bal
des ego pour construire ensemble la
dynamique et le projet alternatif que le
pays attend les pacers à moi je crois
qu'on est là on joue quoi qu'on peut
sortir de l'auberge ci a la volonté de
travailler ensemble pour servir
l'intérêt général merci noir sur les
nazis envers cette chef de file de
l'opep la merci d'arrêter ce matin dans
son crédit
merci
[Musique]